all these other things you did it's like
you work and you work and you know that
you believe in yourself and you go I'm
bigger than what I'm being offered I'm
bigger than this and you know it and the
people who represent you know it but
you're like no you don't understand it I
I I've had those feelings and then when
you suddenly get validated for me it's
it's like it's almost like your dad who
never says any says hey I'm proud of you
it's like it just validates everything
you've been thinking getting to that
place for me was realizing I am bigger
than my career not in an egotistical way
but right I am more than just my career
I had this moment of existential crisis
where I had to ask myself honest
questions about who I was and where my
identity lied and at the time it was an
Ambitions it was in material things and
it was when I decided I'm more than my
career what if my career were to
disappear tomorrow it happens to people
all the time in our business